- You furry flea!
- [Narrator] Villains from 80's cartoons
had a similar sound.
- You overgrown fur coat!
You let him get away!
(click)
- [Narrator] And there
was a reason for that.
Most were voiced by this guy.
- What?
- [Narrator] Alan Oppenheimer.
- My name is Alan
Oppenheimer, and I'm an actor.
- [Narrator] Most famously, he's the voice
of Falkor from NeverEnding Story,
and Skeletor from He-Man.
- (evil giggle) Why are you asking me
these stupid questions?
(villainous laugh)
Get a life! (chuckles)
Regarding He-Man, Masters of the Universe,
I was Skeletor.
I figured the voice would reverberate
inside that bony head.
(nasal voice) So that's why
he went up in here, nasal.
Ha ha ha, you boob!
You idiot!
Why are you bothering living!
(nasal laugh)
You've got a better life somewhere else.
Get out of my face.
- [Narrator] He did some
other villainous voices.
- (evil laugh)
- Grab them, my pet, grab them!
- Cruelty!
- Evil!
- [Narrator] There does seem
to be some relation there.
- I stole from myself.
I mean, hey, if I plagiarize myself
you know, no one can sue me, you know?
- Come in, you royal boob!
- [Narrator] But then, there was Falkor.
- Falkor was the Luck Dragon.
He's kind and he's big and fuzzy.
- [Falkor] (deep, soothing
voice) My name is Falkor.
- And he's flying so you have that feel.
Whoa!
Let's go!
Atreyu!
See?
- (yelling) Ah!
- [Narrator] And he actually
did a few other characters
from NeverEnding Story.
- Very tasty!
- [Alan] (grumbly voice) Oh, I love...
Mmm, quartz is so tasty! Mmm!
Get the picture?
- [Narrator] Alan’s
had an amazing career.
For me, though, I like Falkor.
Alan, will you do the voice again?
- Atreyu, get on my back and we'll fly!
Oh, there are those bullies,
let's get them! (deep, gentle laugh)
(deep, gentle laugh)
Okay.
(friendly laugh)
- [Narrator] Yes!
(ding)